hi i'm andrew heaton fake news and this
is mostly be dishonest media today we're
talking about fake news fake news fake
news think news 8 news I just wanted to
fit in but first I want to speak to you
dear viewer now I don't know much about
you I don't know whether you're watching
me from your home toilet or someone
else's toilet I do know you have
excellent taste in webseries but without
knowing whether you're supporting
President Trump or president Winfrey I
think I can convince you that Donald
Trump creates fake news now Trump claims
to be the arbiter of fake news he says
he coined the term and he very
presidentially handed out fake news
awards last month this is a major honor
the winner is failing New York Times
[Applause]
[Music]
it's really just an honor to be
nominated the Trump is not the arbiter
of fake news Trump is the typhoid mary
of fake news he's the progenitor he's
like a conspiracy theory manifesto
written by a ghostwriter who plagiarized
a magician who reveals it was all an
evil twins dream within the matrix or am
i - how does Trump create fake news two
ways one he makes his detractors so
crazy they forget their journalistic
integrity in their race to pillory him
they bungle cherry-pick or even make up
facts to confirm their hatred and number
two he flat-out lies most recently
and most of those are from this month
now to be fair I understand the pressure
Trump is under to lie I feel it every
time I talk to my 7 million viewers
about my Jack deltoids I get it but
Trump goes above and beyond any normal
amount of lying it was the biggest
electoral college win since Ronald
Reagan no we've signed more bills nope
my father gave me a small loan of a
million dollars also nope and I was just
endorsed by ice I don't know nope some
of the media is terrific but most of it
70% 75% is absolute dishonest absolute
scum according to that same study eighty
six point two percent of reporters are
very sad losers with the worst ratings
yet there is some truth to media suckage
sometimes the media Stoops to Trump's
level and makes a bunch of unforced
errors here's a list of several facts
the media got wrong about Trump
this isn't Diet Coke and those are just
the errors from major news outlets this
misinformation is then disseminated by
your well-meaning but hysterical Trump
hating friends on social media it's part
of a phenomenon called Trump derangement
syndrome or TDs
now unfortunately TDS is a term coined
by the alt-right but hey even a racist
clock is alright twice a day Trump
derangement syndrome is when people are
so blinded by their rage against Trump
that they don't check their facts and
they reflexively oppose anything he
likes do you suffer from TDs symptoms
may include aneurysms sore throat here
removal myopia [ __ ] hat rash twitter
friends a Hitler comparison itis chronic
over posted jump cuts jump cuts
hyperbole hyperventilation hysteria
hyperbole vent hysteria TDS is caused by
alarmism cherry-picking data
confirmation bias [ __ ] reflux
inflated opinion click peg fatigue or a
rush to publish if you suffer from TDs
ask your doctor to tell you to stop it
just stop it please
the worst part is no one needs to suffer
from tedious because there's no need to
exaggerate Trump already says and does
terrible stupid things
it's like spreading a rumor that the
gymnastics bluster also hates Black
History Month he's already a bad guy we
don't need to make stuff up but the
difference between Trump and the media
is the Trump lies all the time and we've
come to expect it
Trump's lies are obvious and
self-serving here's an analogy what
makes you think I ate the chocolate cake
but the media's misreporting is more
subtle and when the media slacks off it
bolsters Trump's accusations of fake
news which confirms his supporters
suspicions of media bias and emboldened
him to keep citing alternative facts
which in turn and rages the media which
in turn and rages Trump so it's a
feedback loop within a repetitive cycle
circulating within a self-propagating
continuous system or am I the way out of
that cycle is for the media to not slack
off and since that probably isn't going
to happen anytime soon readers should
always be skeptical as Supreme Court
justice Abraham Lincoln once said don't
believe everything you see on the
Internet we'll fix that in post
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]